お願いします えーと 今日のテーマは
何にも必ず限度があるという
適度を知って快適に生きるという
限度というあの言葉なんですね
なかなかまあ 世の中を見るとね
よくあることで限度を乗り越えちゃうんですね
限度を乗り越えても 何かそれにも何か言い訳はするんです
お釈迦様の時代でも有名な話がありましてね
このお釈迦様の親しい国王がね
孝昭国王がすごいたくさん食べてるんだということで
食べてからものすごく苦しくなるんだって
だから国王がまあ自分が限度を乗り越えているということはあまり気にしないかったし
おそらく孝昭王様はまあ
まあ職業上でまあしょうがないと思っていた可能性もあります
だから王様の食事だから
ものすごい丁寧に真剣に作って
ものすごいお祭りで まあ食事の用意をしてあげますからね
だから それぞれの義務を果たしている人々に対して
王様の場合も何かしなくちゃいけないんですね
だから スープ担当の人が一生懸命腕を振るってスープを作ったところで
ここは今日はスープ食べませんよと
言うと やっぱりその人たちもかわいそうでしょうし
やる気を失っちゃうし
だから政治家であるし
管理者でもあるしね まあなんとかして一般人を管理しておかなくちゃいけない
そういうことだから もしかするともう用意したものは全部食べてやったでしょうね
でも本人がものすごく苦しい
体が倒れるぐらい苦しいんです
ある日 お釈迦様はまあ昼出かける用事がありまして
食事後すぐ出かけて 一旦出かけたら必ずお釈迦様にも会います
お釈迦様に会いましたけど
座っていられないんですね
苦しくて お釈迦様がまあ体調は悪いんでしょうかと聞いたら
まあお釈迦様にはもう大導師ですから
もう何でも言うんですね
不満は まあ実はこれが毎日のことだと
食事をしてからはもうかなり私はひどい苦しみますよと
それで あの このエピソードは
あまりたくさん食べる人にダイエットしたい人々にはそれほど役に立たないと思いますけど
そんなだるしない人ではなかったんだからね
国王は お釈迦様はすぐ分かったんですね
これが  この人はどうしようもなくもう苦しんでいるんであって
人々の機嫌を取ってやろうと思ってね
それでちょっとまあ あまり食べることはちょっと良くない
まあかっこ悪いというふうな芸人をお釈迦様が問いたんですけど
それは国王に言ったわけじゃないんです
お世話係の人に言ったんです
身の回りのお世話する大臣の家来
大臣閣下と書くですけど
家来にこれはあなた覚えておきなさいよと
だから問題は家来にあったみたいんです
あなたは覚えておきなさいよと覚えておいて
王様が食事して 最後の一口食べる時は
食べる前にこの芸を唱えてくださいと
お釈迦様はこの間こういうことを教えてくれたと
そうすると 国王 国王がその一口食べないんだよと
いくらなんでも食べ過ぎはかっこ悪いっていう芸だからね
次の日 料理を作る時 あなたは残したご飯を全部 1粒1粒数えてくださいと
数えて それぐらい量ね
台所に言ってくださいと
王様が食べ物を残しましたと
だから残すのは何かとんでもないことみたいですね
ですから これ分のこれぐらい残しましたから
食事を減らしなさいよと
残したっていうこと 食べられなかったっていうことだからね
だからそれぐらいの量を減らす
次の日 それで次の日もまた最初最後の一口食べをすると
大臣があの芸を言う それで一口は食べないことになる
それでまた次の日 ほら
また今日王様が残りましたからね
これぐらい残しましたよと
なんで料理たくさん作るの？減らしなさいと
その分を ちょうどその分だけ減らすと
それでまた 3日目も同じことで
最後の一口食べようと思うと
思うと もうあの大臣があの芸を唱える
芸を唱えると 王様も格好悪いんだからやめますと
それやめちゃうんですね
それでまた台所でその分料理を減らすんです
それで これですぐ続けてやってくださいと
それでやがて まあ半年とか 3ヶ月半ぐらい経ったところで
まあ台所に聞いてください
今どれぐらいご飯炊いてますか？と言ったら
まあまあ 一人分 何て言いますか
1合ぐらい だよと言いますよと
だから王様は食べる米も特別なものなんです
そんなたくさん大量にあるわけじゃないんです
お釈迦様もそうでしたけど
再家の時は特別な米なんです
1合ぐらいと言ったところで
あなたあの芸を言うのはやめなさいよと
それで国王が全然気づくこともなく
何のことなく 普通の人間の一人前ぐらい食べられるようになってしまったんですよ
それどうせ運動している人々だから
まあものすごいたちまち体がしっかり締まってきて
楽になったんです それで自由に動けるわ
もう軍事演習は何のことなくできるわ
もう走れるわ 飛べるわ
ここはもう楽しくてしょうがなかったんですね
同時にしきたりもそのまま破ってないんです
王様に用意するものは全部王様は食べる
一つも残さ残さず しかし
食べ過ぎにもならないという
これはまあ世の中で真似できることじゃなくて
ブッダだからこそ 厳密に心理学的に科学的に治療方法をするんであってね
他 世間にはできることじゃないんです
だからブッダのやり方って
というのは そう簡単に真似はできませんし
それまあ性格に合わせてぴったし言うんですから
だからそのエピソードで見えるのは
国王が大食家でグルメでだらしなかったというわけじゃないんです
彼が王としてしっかりと自分の義務を果たしているだけ
そちらにも晩餐会もありますからね
だからいくら糖尿病や高血圧でいたっても
もう国王だからもうどうしようもないんです
一応そういう政治家 国王みたいな人々にとっては
全然わがままは通じないんですよ
だから一般人がそれにしてみれば
わがままないいところで
あれは嫌い これは嫌いとかね
ケーキ食べられないと言っちゃうと
隠れてでも食べるというか
なんで食べられないと言うんでしょうかとかね
そんなわがままはもう一般人に通じるんです
頭悪くて性格悪くてもどうったことはないんだからね
わがまま通じるんですけど
立派な人々にはわがまま通じません
いつでも立派になる人には自我がないんですよ
ちやほやされている 尊敬されているように見えるんですけど
みんな自我を消すって
一生懸命みんなのために頑張っているんです
ですから  あのエピソードは決して食べ過ぎな人にいい例示ということになりませんだけど
一応食べ過ぎはいけないというね
あのことは仏教ではよくあることで
まあ何でもこの適度してすごいスマートにするのは仏教の特色なんですね
あんまり派手に何もしません
何でもかんでもすごくスマート過ぎで主義で
コンパクト的で 合理主義で
まあ脳裏を考えて 何やっても特別にお釈迦様に教えてもらわなくても
そういうコンパクトにやるんです
でお釈迦様と比丘たちにたまたまね
たくさんお布施をもらったりする時もありましたし
その時もやっぱり明日には置いておかないんです
今日 100 人  100 人しかお坊さんたちがいないんだけど
500人分ぐらいの食事を持ってきたと
だからって残りはじゃあ明日にしましょうと
これは そうすると明日托鉢に出なくても大丈夫やっていうことは絶対しません
そうなってくるとコンパクト主義がなくなるんです
今日 1 日分は食べて全部処分するんです
だから弁当買って食べているような感じなんですね
弁当は量も全部一応計算してあって
弁当は全部食べられるし
それで片付いたらきれいさっぱり何もないということで
ですから 大量に食事の残したら
それはもう捨てるかというと
捨てません それでも周りの人々
みんなに配るんです そういうことだから
お釈迦様が托鉢して 比丘たち托鉢して
ご飯いただいて召し上がりますけど
一般の乞食やらね 食べ物ない人々やら
またそれまた逆にもらって自分たちも食べる
だからかなり無駄なく生きてきた世界なんです
だから 現代社会の考え方とはもう何でもかんでも反対なんですね
やっていることは 現代はいかに無駄をするのかということはすごい自慢でしょうし
いかに贅沢するのかとかね
といっても 何の贅沢をしているのかもわからないし
だからそういうもう思考はなかったんです
いつでも論理的で そういうことだから
限度について考えています
限度っていうのは常識ですけどね
誰も守ってないことだけですね
問題は 物事に限度があることをほとんど忘れて生活するんです
これ微妙に ただ食べるもののことに限るわけじゃないんです
仏教の真理に入ります
ですから この 限度があるということは
みんな科学勉強なさってる方々は知ってるでしょうにね
そんな不思議なことじゃないんです
コンセントから電気取ったっても
各コンセントからどれくらい電力を取れるかっていうことは
もう限度が決まってます
その上取ろうとしちゃうとブレーカーが上がっちゃうんです
ブレーカーもあまり機能しないと火事になっちゃうんです
だから限度はありますよ
あるんだけど 問題は我々はそれ軽く忘れるんですね
取り返しつかない問題が起こる
限度が超えちゃうと 起こる問題っていうのは解決できないんです
それだけ覚えておいてください
毎日人間何やっても問題が起こる
しかし解決できます 限度を超えたならば
もう取り返しはつかないんです
そこがとても危ないところなんです
例えば もう 誰がした失敗に別の人に怒鳴ったりする
勘違いして 失敗でしょうね
しかし それはなんとかなります
しかし 怒鳴る場合は限度を超えたならばどうなるのかというと
もうどうにもならなくなっちゃうんです
だから世の中で我々は日々毎日失敗しますけど
まあそこをなんとかなんとかなんとか解決はできます
限度を超えたところで
もうどうにもならなくなるということだけ覚えておきましょう
理性と落ち着くがなく
感情中心に生きることのトラブルが起こるんです
で このトラブルが起こるんですね
人間がなんで限度を破ってしまうかというと
理性がない ほとんど理性で物事を考えません
面白いことに よく私に文句言うでしょ
妄想やめなさいと言ったって困りますよとかね
自分が医者だから 弁護士だから
あれやこれやだから 教師だからね
よく考えなくちゃあかんではないかとか言うのは言うんだけど
ほとんど理性使ってないんで
理性使ってるならばそんな判断もしないんです
みんな理性ではなくて感情で妄想したり判断したりする
だから限度っていうのは超えてしまうんです
限度を知って平安で生きる人は感情に勝った人で
理性の人なんです だから感情に勝った人
いわゆる感情を乗り越えた人が限度の中でしっかり生きていられる
生きているんです 生きるんです
理性の人なんです ですから
世の中で人間がかなり限度を超えて超えて
とんでもない問題 どうしても解決できない問題ずっと作っているんです
世の中を見るとわかると思います
世の中 現代 我々にある問題はどうやって解決するのかと
どんな問題でも国際問題しか私は知らないんだけど
取り上げてみてください
解決はあるのかと ないんです
みんな限度を超えているんです
ものすごい危険なことで
ものすごい残念なことで
まあ国際的に言えば パレスチナとイスラエルの
問題があります ずっと 50 年間も殺し合い殺し合いでやりすぎだから解決方法はない
じゃあイラクの問題に解決はあるのかというとないんです
やりすぎ 北朝鮮の問題
解決できると思いますかね
もう限度を超えているんです
何でもそうやってもう国際的に目立っても
まあ限度を超えている
海は汚染されてますよ
じゃあどうやって 綺麗にしますかね
それは国際的に 個人的にもどこでも我々はまあよく限度を超えちゃってるんだから
もう解決方法はない 例えば石油を運ぶタンカーという大型の船ありますね
自然は破壊してない しかし
何か事故が起こして もうタンカーがもう壊れちゃって油が漏れたと
それなんと解決はありますよ
それでも油を取ったり
海の中に沈むようにしたりとか
海の中に沈んだっても
油にしたっても 時間経つと栄養になるんです
だから微生物はそれを栄養にして何かなる
しかし 今は無理です もう限度を超えているんです
だから海はもともと綺麗であったならば
たまたまの事故っていうのは耐えられます
はい それからこの限度って何なのかと勉強し
これから仏教の話に入ります
勉強してみます 限度っていうことは
別の言葉で言えば 何の不思議もなく
アニッチャという無常という言葉なんです
何の不思議なことでもないんです
仏教で有名な単語でサッベーサンカーラアニッチャーという言葉がありまして
一切の行は無常ですというね
サンカーラっていうのは
組み立てた 出来上がった
合成したもので 独立して自立して存在するものではありません
だから物事は合成されているんです
組み立てたものなんです
自分の体も組み立てたもので
着ている服も組み立てたもので
この椅子も机も全部組み立てたもので
花一輪があったらそれも組み立てたもので
すべてのものは組み立てたもの
それからものでない概念にしたっても
組み立てるものなんです
頭の中で 現象という単語を使います
ですから サンカーラという言葉に現象という言葉はまあ一応適しています
ですから すべての現象は無常であると
ですから 一切の現象は無常です
現れては消えるものです
日本語でこの諸行無常と言っているのはそういうことですね
漢文で諸行無常と言ったってもわからないんですね
だから我々は頭で考える概念も作ったもので
耳に聞こえる音も作ったもので
原子一個見たっても作られたもので
組み立てて出来上がるもので
だから自立していないんです
だから壊れるんです だから限度っていうのは自ずと成り立っているんです
組み立てたんだから どこまで支えて支えられるのかっていうことは
当然ありとあらゆるものにあるんです
それで現象の特色は何なのかと
組み立てたら何かを永遠にはなりません
組み立てたものだから
本物じゃありません 作り物だから
すべて 結婚式の砂隠しみたいに
まあ作り物ばっかりで本人どこにいるかわからないんですね
現象というのはパティッチサムッパンナン
因縁により起こるという
いわゆるこれがまあ簡単じゃない
このパティッチサムッパンナンというパーリ語の訳は
まあコンディショナルということなんですけど
英語で言えば コンディショナルコーセティフという
まあ英語の単語は作れますけど
なかなか日本語にはならん
いわゆる独立していないという意味で
まあなんとかなんとか支えられているだけ
次はカヤダンマンワヤダンマン
まあ減る老いるものですね
どんな現象もどんどん減って能力なくなってしまうんです
まあ生命だったら老いるんです
物質ならまあどんどん
あの 何て言いますか なんとかなくなっていくんです
英語の世界ではエントロピーという単語がありますけど
これは物理化学では別な意味でね
あの あの サーモダイナミクスという化学物理化学分野ありますね
この 熱力学 まあそちらでは何か計算する時の使う一つのまあファクターですけど
エントロピーは まあそれはあんまり仏教的な使えない単語ではある
しかし 社会学でのエントロピーという単語を使います
ソーシャロジーの場合では
ソーシャロジーの場合は
社会のエントロピーというのは
社会はどんどん壊れて壊れて
もうだらしない状態になってもう終わりになっちゃうというね
これは止まりませんと止められませんと
カオスというね それがエントロピーという単語を使っています
とにかくまあどちらでもいいんだけど
原子一個でもずっとそのままでいるわけじゃないんです
変わるんです 次の特色はニローダダンマ
滅するんです なくなるんです
その現象が 一つの現象を作っても
作った時点からそれはエントロピーになっちゃうんですね
エントロピーになってからパーッと消えちゃうんです
壊れてしまうんです だから何にストップ？すべての物事は止まれないんです
ずーっと流れて変わっていくんです
ヴィラーガダンマ 同じ
に値する 執着に値しない
ですから 現象に執着するのは馬鹿者なんです
理性のある人はどんな現象にも執着しない
だってエントロピーでやってすぐ壊れますからね
価値がないんです だからこの世の中にも価値がないんです
一切の生命も現象だからね
何の価値もないんです
だからそれはもう悟りの境地に達するために理解しなくちゃいけない知恵なんです
物事に価値をつけるんじゃないんで
価値つけても価値が減っていくんだからね
だから あの 何といいますか
落札なんとかやってるような感じで
時間的に値段変わるでしょ
インターネットもよくやってるでしょ
時々もう10万  20万
30万の品物でも出してますよ
もう最初は10円でいいんだよという
だから出した途端10円で誰かいるかもしれませんだけど
それからちょっと2時間経ってまたインターネットアクセスしてみると 10
円のところじゃないんですよ
値段かなり上がってるんです
だからそんな感じで 店の品物にしても
値札はもう貼っておくんじゃなくて
やっぱり時計をつけた方がいいんですね
もう時間と一緒に値段も変わるという
その方が正しいんですよ
だって何かもう魚でも何でももう売りに出しても
それからずっとあれは変化していくんだから
やがて賞味期限消えていくんだから
だからそれに合わせて時計
タイマーをつけておけばどうですかね
あと 値札に ICチップをつけちゃって
全部まあ 1 分ごとに値段は減っていくと
そうすると賞味期限がなってきて
もうあともう 20 分ぐらいない場合は
10円ぐらいとかね 前はもう本当はもう 2,500円でしたけどとか
そうすれば正しいですよ
論理的には あとはこのコンビニだったらね
賞味期限になってから全部持ってそのまま捨てるでしょうね
安くしてはおりません
決まってる値段は決まってる値段で
だからものすごい資源破壊なんです
それよりはちょこっとプログラム入れてあげて
品物に賞味期限がありますから
特に生物の場合は早いでしょうね
だから時間と一緒にどんどんどんどんどんどん値段が減るようにしておけば
そこで賞味期限が来たらピーッとなって0になって
売り売り売り なんて言いますか
売って売れないという
それであれを零細にさせても
これはもうピーピーと売れませんと
これは簡単です それでお客さんにちょっと5分前に来たならばね
それを買えたのにと と言えるし
だから全ての現象には価値がないんで
とにかく壊れますからね
で 価値がない だから執着するに値しない
だから一切現象に執着しない気持ちになった人は悟りに達しているんです
物質だけではなく 心も同じ
無常なのです わかりやすいのは物質の無常ですけど
本当は心も同じくエントロピーで変化していくんです
で よく世の中ある話は常住永住論ですね
諸行は無常ですが 行でないものは非無常ではないでしょうかという
まあへんてこりなことを考えるんですね
これ 仏教の人々なんですよ
まあ決まって頭が悪いんだからね
これほど偉大なる教えあるにも関わらず
世間でもう追い出されているでしょうに
仏教の人々にも まああのシラミ1匹ぐらいの脳細胞があったならば
もう世界は支配しているはずなんです
すべての人類に仏教を教えて
みんなに幸福平和な生き方を教えてあげるはずなんです
ここで偉大なる仏様 神様と尊敬している人々はたくさんいますけど
歴史上では でも脳細胞はシラミに負けるでしょうね
だから人類に迷惑かけ
まあ物質的な迷惑をかけてないんだけど
精神的に迷惑をかけたんですよ
修行しなくてもいいやというところまで持っていったんだから
頑張らなくてもいいんだよと
怠けでふざけていいんだよと堂々と言うところまで行きました
そういうことを言うならば
かなり人気も出てくる
いっぱい人がね 頭の悪い連中が聞くんだから
喋ってる人も自分が本当に立派な仏教の先生やとか思ってるんです
思って私にも何か言おうかなと言って
むきば降りちゃいます
その時は だから持ってくるポイントは
あなたにそれほど人がいないでしょうと
私が言うのは 世の中で知識人は少ないでしょ
天才は少ないでしょ バカはいくらでもいますよと
だから何をと それで生行無常なら行でないものは無常じゃないでしょ
単語を入れ替えているだけ
だから単語を勝手に単語と遊んではいけません
この単語は一旦シンボルだからといって
シンボリックロジックには合わないんです
例えば何でしたっけ？あれは色即是空
合ってます 色は空だから
実体ないんだから 空即是色っていうのはなりませんよ
A イコール Bと言ったならば
B イコール A です だから色即是空
空即是色っていうのはよっぽどもう学校に行ってないでしょうね
だって空っていうのは全体的なものですよ
全体的な真理 色っていうのは現象の一部なんです
一部はすべてですと言ったら
変でしょう だから私はそれをわかりやすく出す
例はリンゴは果物です
ただ丸でしょ 果物はリンゴですと言ったらどうなるんですかね
リンゴは果物ですと言ったところで
リンゴと果物の単語を入れ替えたらダメなんです
順番で順番もう変われないんです
しかし  A イコール B と言ったら
B イコール A です それは大丈夫です
そういうことで 生業は無常と言ったら
じゃあ行でないものはどうせ無常でないということになるんです
それで考えちゃったんだ
無常でないものは極楽道
大日如来 いくらでも作るんです
この人の知らないのは自分たちが作ったんだから
これも生業であることなんです
何のデータもなく頭で作った概念だからね
それさえも生業に入りますよとわからないんです
大日如来は光仏 ブッダは永遠にいるんですね
そうやって仏教の世界ではまあかなり脱線してしまったんです
サンカーラ サンカタに対するアサンカーラ
アサンカタというコンセプトがあります
だから その人々はそういう理屈に飛び込んだのは当然
仏教でサンカーラに対するアサンカーラという単語があるんで
コンセプトは しかし サンカタもアサンカタも両方まとめてしょう
諸法無我 サッデーダンマアナッターと説いてます
だからどうにもならないんです
ブッダに教えてあげることはできません
残念でした なぜならば
お釈迦様は諸行無常と言ってから
諸法無我と言うんです
その場合は行入れ替えて法にするんです
法にしたらサンカタもアサンカタも両方入るんです
無我というのは実体も何もないということなんです
空ということなんです
だから まあそういう屁理屈は成り立たないんです
変わらない実体はないという意味です
一切皆苦もおなじみです
仏教で一切皆苦というね
だから色即是空だけ合ってます
一切皆苦だけ合ってます
しかし 経典 大乗経典続けて読んじゃうとまるっきりあべこべになるんです
無常には断固反対と 生命は無常を発見しようとしない
無常に遭遇すると悩む
悲しむ 苦しむ 毎日我々は悩んだり
悲しんだり 苦しんだりしていますよ
それは無常に操縦遭遇するんだからなんです
現象変わることなく 常にあってほしいと思うんです
変わるのは嫌です ということは
無常に断固反対ということなんです
反対できるんでしょうかと
それはどうでもいいんです
とにかく反対ですと 反対だからこそ
あらゆる苦しみが生まれてくるんです
なくなって欲しくないものがなくなると悲しいんですよ
悔しいんですよ 死んで欲しくない人が死ぬと
ものすごく我慢できないんです
だから年取ってくると
なんでそんなに嫌なのかというと
年取りたくないんだからなんです
体力が減ると なんでそんなに嫌なのかというと
やっぱり年を取って欲しくないんです
地震が起きて家が潰れ潰れちゃったらなんで悲しむんですかね？わかりやすいでしょ
地震は起きてほしくない
家は潰れてほしくないんです
もし人が潰れるものなら潰れと
起こるものなら地震が起これと
気にするもんかと そしたら地震が起きたらその人怖くなったり怯えたりする？しない
勝手にしろよと いう気分でいるならば
何のこともないです しかし
勝手にしろよとは思わないでしょうに
家を作る時はとにかく耐震強度ということは考えて
まああの なんとか八卦占い
なんとかありますね 水晶あれ
あの何か円盤持って占いますね
あれはなんてます？風水占いで地震が起こらない場所を探して家を作るんです
だから占い師はもう商売繁盛しますよ
皆様の頭いいんだからね
無常に反対だから 大したもんだよ
ブッダに逆らってますからね
これは論理ではなく感情
気持ちです それで人間のこの無常反対
断固反対ということは理屈じゃないんです
理性じゃない ただ感情
気持ち 自分の親はね まあ死ぬでしょうと知ってますよ
しかし 気持ちでは絶対嫌という
だから親が死んじゃうと悲しくなるんです
生きている場合は気にするもんかと平気で面と向かって言うんです
そう言いながら 亡くなったと聞いた途端もう落ち込んじゃうんです
だから理屈じゃないんです
みんな変わってほしくないという気持ちで
感情で生きているんです
人間の希望はいかに現象を変えられない状態で保たれるのかということです
だからもう科学のほとんどもうこういう方向へも変わらないようにしてやるぞという
よく頑張った しかし これは無理
不可能で失望します だから科学も医学部も何でもかんでも見事に失望します
一生懸命お金なくしてなくして無駄に使ってやっていますけど
何かやっているんですかね
人類について 何もやってないんです
人類の幸福のために 安らけのために
仏教以外 世の中誰も何もやってないんです
ただ 金むちゃくちゃ使って
ヴァティカンまでセントピーターズベシリカとかね
システィーナチャペルとか
もうもう人類の全財産集めたって作れないぐらいのものを作ったりはします
あれで何かやってくれるんでしょうかというと
何もないんです だから科学研究もすごい大量にね
財産使って何かやってくれているのかというと
何もないんです 我々の人生は昔と何の変わりもないんです
苦労して生きていて 年取って死ぬの
昔も病気になったところで
お医者さんがお手上げ
治療はするんだけど もうその前に死んじゃうんですね
今も同じことです どうにもならないんです
お医者さんは頑張ります
無常に逆らってやろうと
頑張ってもどうにもならないんです
それで無常ということ
で 物事に限度が成り立つんです
それで因縁ということも勉強した方がいいんです
アスミンサティ イダンホーティ
アスミンアサティ イダンナホーティという有名な公式ですね
あれがある時 これがある
あれがない時 これがないという
物事はそういう風に成り立っているんです
現象は なんとかなんとかなる時もあるんだけど
なんとかなんとかない時はこれもないんです
そういうすべてのものは互いに支え合って生きている
生きてるんじゃないんです
起きているんです あらわになるんです
誰か誰かないとね ただ
皆様はこのパソコンから文字があって映してくれると思っているでしょう
そんなのはないんです
こちらがこういう何とかないと文字は存在しないんです
もし壁がなかったら スクリーンなかったら何もないでしょう
パソコンでプロジェクターでいくら頑張っても存在さえしない
そこでパソコンとプロジェクターと電気と
みんなお互いに支え合って
もう壁ももう余裕 スクリーンあって
はい それでもう文字が映るんだという現象が一時的に成り立つんです
これが一時的 電気が流れている間だけ
それでコンピューターの電気の流れに合わせて
ずっと電気の流れを変化してくれないと
だからコンピューターはどのように変化するのかと決めるんです
光は電気は流れているんです
同じスピードで その流れをいろいろ変化させるんです
それで文字が存在するんです
だから互いあらゆる助け合って
これが結果です もし原因消えちゃうとすぐ消えるんです
1個だけでも消えると終わりですよ
原因たくさんですけど
全ての現象は現れる時
因と縁によって現れるので
常に条件付きなのです
独立自立できません 物事はいつでも条件付き
独立自立っていうのは成り立たないという
これが全てのものに限度があるということ
だから全てのものに限度がある
世の中でダイヤは一番強いと思ってるでしょ
しかし金槌で潰れますけど
ダイヤで何でも鉄でも何でも削れます
工業用にいろんなものにはダイヤの粉塗ってるでしょ
今 包丁も研ぐためにこのダイヤの粉を粒子状態にしてボンドで塗って固めておいて
だから包丁ちょっと2 3回削ったらもう研いだらもう切れる
ダイヤは強いんです しかし
間違ってでも こういう石の中にでもちょっとなっちゃうと終わります
限度があるんです それでも
だからまあ一切の物事現象には限度があるんです
一切の現象は条件付きなんです
これ一切現象という言葉を覚えて
現象でないものって何ですか？アサンカーラは
たった一つしかないんです
涅槃だけ だから我々知ってる全てのものは現象なんです
1,000円で美味しいものを食べられる
美味しくなる これ たとえ話
1,000円あればね
本当に美味しいものを食べられるぞという条件があるんです
ということは 1万 10
万  100万円を使うことによって
美味しさが10倍 100
倍 1万倍に増えるということではありませんね
限度があるんです  1,000円でこんな美味しいものを食べられるんだから 1
万あったら10倍はないんです
限度があるんです 最良は諸原因もろもろの原因の一つだけです
だから  1万円で考えるのは最良のことだけなんですよ
原因まだあります   1,000円で考えるのは最良のことなんです
味の感覚 容量 消化能力
体力 体重 歳などのたくさん原因があって
美味しいという結果が出てくるんです
お腹に入る容量も関係あるんです
だから  1,000円で美味しいものを食べられるぞということは
1,000円だけじゃないんです
1,000円さえあれば
美味しいものを食べられるならば
2,000円で2倍食べ美味しくなるんです
1万円で10倍美味しくなるんです
しかし  1,000円はたった1個の原因
自分の体力 自分の年 自分に食べられる容量
自分の消化能力 感覚 あれこれや原因たくさんあります
結果はすべての原因が調和するところです
それであらゆる原因は調和して結果が出てくるんです
余計に一つの原因を増やしたんだからといって結果良くならないんです
例えば 植物は立派な花を咲かせるためには窒素が必要ですよ
窒素でしたっけ だからといっていろいろ
まあ英語ではもうユーリッカス
ユーリア ナイトレードとかなんとか化学名ありますけど
そういうものは入れちゃえばパッと花が咲きますよ
しかし 少量しか入れられません
あの耳かき ぐらい 耳かきぐらい入れたら
熱中症でこんな花が咲いたんだから
では大さじ2杯入れるそうと言っちゃうと 2
時間以内で死にます 植物は
だから一つの原因が増えた
増やしたんだからといって良い結果は出ません
だから世の中よくそれをやるでしょうに
だからバラバラ無茶苦茶になっているんです
子供はなんとかちょこっと問題を起こしたんだったから
いきなり校則だけ作っていく
それで解決しませんよ
一つだけ原因じゃないんだから
いつでも世間はもう何か一つの原因を探して
じゃあそれ変えましょう
またたくさん原因ありますよ
だから結果っていうのはすべての原因の調和のところで
で これは何でしたっけ？早いか遅いかという
人々は物事の因縁を変えて
変化を早くしたり遅くしたりする
それ仏教の世界で我々はいろんなことをやってますよ
何をやっているのかというと
しかし 常に限度があるんです
まあ例えばね 新幹線を作ったり
えーと 今日はもう12時までやりそうになりますみたい
もう傘持ってきていないんです
じゃあ早く終わります
えーと 新幹線作ったり
いろんなことやってますでしょ
早くしてますね また いろんなものを遅くさせたりするでしょ
だって皆様 スーパーで買う豚肉っていうのは
もう1年前 半年前 死んだものでしょ
わかりませんよ 食べてる魚なんかは
いつ死んだものかとわかりません
ただ 新鮮 新鮮なものだと言ってあげれば
はい わかりました  そういうことだからね
だからそれで冷凍技術がありまして
腐ることは遅くする 新幹線は動きを速くする
人間やっていることは
物事の変化を当然変化しますよ
変化を早くするか遅くするかと
たったそれだけのこと
だからといって限度がありますよ
新幹線を速くするんだからといって
100 500キロとかはできません
今300キロを自慢してますけど
一度でも300キロで走ってないんです
調べてください 走ってないんです
あれ 自慢だけでリミットがあるんです
ただ走れば走れますけど
周りあれうるさくて振動で裁判かけたらどうしますかね
その原因も考えなくちゃいけない
で ものすごいスピードで走るならば
一旦東京からスタートしたら
大阪で泊まるしかないんです
そうすると大阪に行く人々だけでも
JR にはもう収益がなくなっちゃうんです
そうすると新幹線の維持管理できなくなるんです
だから品川から新横浜から
結局各駅停車状態になっている
これでスピードは出せないんです
それがすべての原因調査したところの結果なんです
だから限度があるんです
例えば豆を普通の鍋で茹でるより
圧力鍋の場合は時間は短いでしょ
私は一応わかりやすい例えを出してます
皆様は料理なんか作ったことないでしょうな
店で買うんだからね あの圧力鍋に入れちゃうと
どんな硬いものでもすぐ柔らかくなります
ものすごい短時間で では
時間を 3 秒に縮めますかと
縮めますかね 豆を 3 秒でふっくらと茹でてあげるそうと
これは無理です  3時間コトコト煮るべきものは
圧力鍋なら 30分には減ります
それは限度で それ以上はできません
因果法則を超えられない
これよく覚えておきましょう
すべて因果法則だから
一つも超えられないんです
新幹線 音速 飛行機 ロケット
宇宙船などを作っても
因縁の範囲内で働かなくてはならないんです
彼らがもうブッダに逆らって因果法則を破ってますかね
誰も破ってないんです
みんな因果法則の中で
因果法則に完璧に従って完璧に克服して仕事をしているんです
因果法則に一言葉言うことはできません
とにかく因果法則 新幹線はあれよりちょこっとでもスピード上げちゃうと変わりますからね
ということだから  長生きすることに成功しても死を避けられません
完全無病はできません
病気は減らしますよ 今もいろんな病気は減ってます
しかし 完全無病状態は作れません
昔の人々よりは今は長生きしているかもしれません
しかし 死を避けることはできません
ブッダによってお腹が空くことも病気
病です なぜならば人間考えているところじゃないんです
我々の体でお腹が空くということが起きるでしょう
ブッダは言うのはそれも病気ですよ
だからどうやって完全無病状態を作るんですかね
お腹が空くことも病気ならどうしますかね
結局お腹が空くということは
体の物質は壊れるという意味ないでしょうね
壊れるものはまた入れ替えなくちゃあんで
だから病気 病気真っ最中でしょうね
壊れっぱなしだから 現れるものは壊れるということは法則なので
人間の戦いも続くでしょう
だから現れたものは壊れる
これ法則です ですから人間も無限に戦うんです
壊れないようにしてやるぞと
だから 人参ぶら下がっているような状態でずっと生きてるんですよ
ロバは一歩進んだら人参も一歩進むんだから
ロバは諦めません もう一歩進むんです
そうすると人参ももう一歩進むんです
で 人参は透けてるものだから
やがてロバが疲れて倒れるんであって
人参はそのまんま だから法則
無常という法則はずっとあるんであって
それに逆らう人間だけくたびれて死んで
またくたびれて死んでくという
もう連続性が成り立つんです
それから だから人間やっているのは発展か後退かということ
人は発展して進化してゆくものなのか
そうその違い なぜある側面で発展すると別な側面で後退するんでしょうかね
いきなり言うでしょう
現代時代ではとか 今発展していてしている社会ではとかね
身国々ではとかね 身心国々なのに
なんで我々よりものすごい頭の大きい問題を抱えて込んでいるんですかね
なんで笑えないんですかね
人は行っているのは発展ではありません
仏教から見れば 人類が社会を発展しているんじゃないんです
発展だったら問題あるはずないでしょう
常に変わる流れの変化の道を
少々変えることです 人間やっていることをよく見てください
物事は変化する 変化すると
ちょこっとこの変化の流れを変えるんです
それでも変化するんです
例えば 石一つ流れてくるんですよ
危ないんです これはそのまま空中で止めることできますか？できません
だから何か当てるものでもあったら
それを当てちゃうと それが別なところに落ちるんです
だから 流れ的に石が落ちることが起きたんです
ただ 流れがこちらに落ちはず落ちるはず
石があちらに落ちただけ
それでよかったと 結果になる
ほら 社会は私は発展しているよと言えますかね
別に何か発展させたわけじゃないんです
世の中の科学世界で経済世界でやっているのは
常に起こる流れの道を少々ちょこっと変える
たくさん変えることもできません
ほんの少々しか ダンマを作っても川に川の流れは止めませんだからね
あるのは発展ではなく変化です
だから自然の変化もあって
我々手加えて変化することもできる
どうせ自然も変化するんだから
まあ大したことはないんです
手加えて危険を招く これで人間が手加える結果は危険なんです
物事の自然な流れを 自然の流れを変え
流れ変化は安全でも危険でも幸福でも不幸でもないんです
世の中で起きている変化は
幸福でも不幸でも危険では何でもないんです
例えば 地球は自転しているわ
公転しているわ 我々にとっては現象的に太陽が昇ったり沈んだりするように見えるわ
で 海は満潮と もう一つありますね
満潮と干潮があるわ 要するに何のこともないんです
火山が爆発するわ 地震が起きるわ
洪水になるわ 時々乾季になるわ
普通の変化 どうとく これ
幸福も不幸でも何でもない
見事に自然にあるべき
なんて言いますか あるべき
としてあるあるものなんです
それに人間が手を加えるんですよ
しかし 人は手を加えてその流れを少々変えるでしょう
そこから危険という現象が現れるんです
牛は自然の葉っぱを食べて太って
年取って死んだりする
肉食べたい人はその牛を殺して食べたりもする
何も問題なかったんです
これ 手を加えたんです
早く太らせてやるそうと
あっちこっち歩いたら困りますよと
歩いちゃうとエネルギー使いますから
その分太りませんよと
お金が無駄になるんだよといって
牛を檻に入れて動かないことにして
早く太るように高タンパク
牛はタンパク質食べません
草だからね 食べるのは
自分の肉食べさせるんです
骨を粉にして 牛骨をね
これで栄養満点だと 昔々のバカな人はね
2年待っていたんだよと
私たちは1年で牛を太らせてみせますよと
これは我々の腕前どうでしょうか
どうなったんでしょうかね BC
になっちゃって 多く短期で損しちゃったんです
手を加えたことで そこで細菌を殺すことを見つけたんですね
細菌は殺されますよ それで人類から病気を取り払ってやるぞと
ペニシリンを発見した時もそう言ったんだからね
その先生は これで人類の病気はなくなるんだよと
本当 で もうむちゃくちゃ
もう 細菌は嫌やと思って薬を使って使って
今 ブドウなんとか菌とかね
院内感染とか もう薬は効かない
今現代は本当にもう病院を消毒したければ
ガスバーナーで全部燃えてあげないと
例えば床はずっとガスバーナーで当てていくと
細菌は死にます 壁にも全部ガスバーナーを当てて
それしかもう残ってないんです
それもやりすぎになっちゃうと
ガスバーナーでも知らない細菌が現れる可能性あります
裏の人の手に入らなかったら
自然界では何の危険もなかったんでしょ
臨海の臨海実験恐れがないでしょう
人間手を加えたんだからなんです
人は手を加えなかったら温暖化もないでしょう
だから人間という人間がやってる発展というのは
自然の流れに手を加えて流れをストップしてるんじゃないんで
できません 不可能 流れ変えるだけ
流れ変えちゃうとより危険な結果出して帰るんです
まあ人間はそんなつもりじゃないんです
一人も地球は暖かくしてやるそうと思ったことはないんです
オゾン層を破ってやるそうと思った人は一人もいません
思ってないんだけど 無知だから
初めから何やっても悪い結果で終わるんです
だから 現代科学 経済国
この流れが仏教から評価すると発展というか後退というか
どちらにするかとわかもわからなくなるんです
危険が生じる原因 なんで人間手を加えると危険ですかね
危険も因縁で生じる 何か因縁があるはずなんです
心には希望 願望 好みなんて言ったっけ
望みという感情があるんです
理屈があるんじゃなくて
感情があるんです 子供が大きくなったら保護者になりたいというのは感情であって
別に理屈あるわけじゃないんです
経験する物事は変わる
好きなものがなくなったり
嫌なものが現れたりする
これで毎日我々はいろんなものを経験しますね
経験する場合は 好きなものは変わっちゃうし
嫌なものは起こるしという現象もあります
それから希望もあります
おのずと手を加えたくなります
ですから 嫌なものは起こるとやっぱり手を加えたくなるでしょう
好きなものは変わっていくとやっぱり
買ってきた花が枯れそうになってくると
やっぱり水を入れたくなるでしょう
それで手を加えるんです
もういても立ってもいられなくなるんです
しかし 因果法則を知り尽くしていないんです
手を加えるんだけど 因果法則を知り尽くしているわけじゃないんです
例えば ダムを作ったりして
いろんなところに水をあげたりするでしょう
それで農業できるんだぞと計算するだけであって
長い時間の何て言いますか
因果法則をわかっていないんです
このこの枯れた土地に水をあげることはとてもいいことやと
あの砂漠にも水をあげることはとてもいいことだと一方的に言うんですけど
サリネーションという問題があります
インサリネーションとも言うんです
土はいっぱい塩が溜まるんです
だから十年で草も生えなくなっちゃうんです
すごいお金かけてダム作って水路を作るんだけど
だから昔風に洪水があった方が良かったんです
農作物も全部流されちゃいます
海に しかし 土に残る塩も持っていくんです
その代わりに泥でかぶってくるんです
それでまた農業できるんです
そこで雨が降らないところに水を流しちゃうと
流した水が蒸発していく
ミネラルだけ残る また次もまた次また
それで塩 だからそこまで考えない
今発展しています なかなかもうダメになっているんだから
いろんなところで 失敗は大量で
成功は少々ということになる
ですから 人間やっている世界は失敗大量にあります
成功は少々 だからそれに発展というんでしょうかと
一千万円なくなったんだけど
ちょこっと商売で百円は儲かってますよ
一個売れたんだよと それで一個売れたら儲けは百円だと
これ一個作るではなくて
この工場には一千万かかりましたよという話です
だから現代発展っていうのはもう赤字がありすぎて
黒字期っていうのは本当に少ないんですよ
そういう流れです 理由は感情と欲望
希望なんです 欲望 希望はあるんだけど
因果法則を知らない 欲望希望あるのももうどうしようもない
だって好きなものは変わるし
嫌なものが起きたりもするし
変化の流れでは 限度を超えると神頼みですね
そこで限度を超える話に入ります
家も人も家も街も自然に変わっていく
問題はありませんよ 家があったとしても
人がいたって街があったっても
自然に変わっていくんです
何の問題もないんです
しかし 街は火事になったら人の管理できる範囲が超えて
町は普通に雨が降ってちょっと困ったとかね
台風が来てちょこちょこっと困ったとか
ああだとかことはないんです
では 火事になったらどうでしょうかと
管理できなくなるんです
地震の場合  地震